In all the cases before, we've been adding like radicals together. And in a
couple of the cases, we couldn't even combine the radicals, because the
radicands were different. Sometimes radicals will appear to be different, but
they're actually alike. We can simplify these radicals to determine whether or
not we can add or subtract them together. For example, we can split up the
square root of 20 into 4 times 5. Then, we can split this radical up into two
separate radicals, using our product rule. We do the same thing for 80 and for
500. Notice that when I split up 80, I split it up into the largest perfect
square. And the same is true for 500. 100 is the largest perfect square that
goes into 500. This allows me to simplify the radicals more quickly. Now that
we have some perfect squares, we can simplify them. The square root of 4 equals
2, the square of 16 equals 4, and the square root of 100 equals 10. We multiply
the remaining factors in front of our radical to get 16 root 5, 12 root 5, and
negative 20 root 5. Notice how we were able to simplify each of these radicals
to radicals that all have a square root of 5. Because these radicals are
identical, we can add and subtract them. We'll have 16 plus 12 minus 20, which
equals 8 times the square root of 5. This is why we learn how to simplify
radicals first, because even though these radicals don't appear to be like, we
can simplify them and then combine them.